Boudicca was an ancient Celtic warrior queen who led an army in rebellion
against the Roman empire.
The story of this brave woman's life has often been reduced to just a few
sentences in a textbook.
And that's because there's very little known about her life.
There were just two Roman historians,
Tacitus and Cassius Dio who wrote down information about Boudicca,
everything we know about her,
it's rather skewed from the enemy's perspective and both of their versions of
the story very slightly from the other. But even from this biased standpoint,
we can still see her bravery and her determination to protect her people.
Despite the fact that we know so little about her life,
she still has made a massive impact and she very nearly defeated one of the
largest empires in the world.
She has still remember to this day as being an epic hero in British history,
The term KET is used to refer to the ancient people of the United Kingdom,
but it covers the gales, Britains and GOs. Just to name a few,
there were dozens of different independent tribes that were certainly not
United. So while their lifestyles were often very similar,
they each had their own customs languages and traditions.
So the name Celts is just away for historians to refer to this ancient society.
The cults did to keep their own written records.
So much of what we know from them comes from Roman records and archeological.
According to the Romans Celtic warriors often fought naked,
or at least with their shirts off their bodies and faces,
they were painted with intricate designs, which ends them. The nickname picked,
which meant the painted people. They weren't known for being incredibly brutal.
And during at they would begin grunting like animals and blue,
loud horns to start all their enemies.
They beheaded the Romans without hesitation because they apparently believed
that a man's head contains his power and his soul,
despite their Bob Eric war strategy. These were also very intelligent people.
They were the first society to invent chain mail,
which protected them from enemy swords.
Both men and women wore gold necklaces that included intricate designs,
paved roads were also CEL convention,
even though the Romans later tried to claim that they came up with the idea
first. So in a lot of ways,
the kelps were far from being the bumbling brute that they're often made out to
beat Boudicca was the queen and wife of king press sous.
And they were rulers of the ISIN tribe. They were located in modern day,
Norfolk and Suffolk. And for a while, their people, they lived in peace,
a Roman statesman and a historian named Cassius Dio described Boudicca as such
in stature. She was very tall in appearance,
most terrifying in the glance of her eye.
Most fierce and her voice was harsh. A great mass of the,
to hair felt to her hips around her neck was a large golden necklace.
And she wore a TNIC of divers colors over which a thick mantle was fastened
with broach. What apparently lacked in grace and beauty. She made up for,
with brilliance, according to DI's backends in compliments,
she possessed of greater intelligence than often belongs to women in Celtic
society.
Drews were intellectuals who held very highly respected positions in their
respective tribes. They were like priests who performed the pagan rituals,
but they also practiced medicine, alchemy science and philosophy. And yes, DRD.
This could be women too, since Boudicca is remembered for being very smart.
It would make sense that she may have been a drew it in her spare time.
Apart from being queen.
This would've only made her a more well respected leader,
but with the new threat of Roman invasion,
Boudicca would need to focus on protecting her people more than ever before
The Romans conquered Southern England in 43 80 king PRUs could see that
his Celtic warriors were no match for the Roman Legion.
So he ordered his warriors to stop their rebellion.
PRUs agreed to align with the Roman empire for the sake of protecting what
remained of his people. He promised that when he died,
his tribe would be on the, a Roman rule in his last will and testaments.
He left his lands to his two daughters and to the emperor of Rome,
the king truly did believe that they had made a peaceful negotiation and the
Romans even L to Britain their currency and helped them to integrate into their
new society. They were given 40 million celss,
but they were expected to pay it back over time. Plus interest,
there is a debate over how much one sester I would actually be worth in today's
money, but the estimates are usually around about $1 and 50 cents.
So their loan was essentially for 60 million.
The prisons never asked for a loan in the first place. In fact,
the Celtic tribal people were rich in resources like gold,
but they accepted the money anyway,
because it was the only way that they could have a currency to buy I and sell
with the Romans Nero took Claudia's place as the new emperor of Rome in the year
54, he was just 16 years old at the time.
And he was known for his extravagant spending in turn.
He sought to regain much of the lost funds by going after interest on loans,
as well as through taxes,
Nero appointed a man named SW POS to handle the new tree that was England.
He was given the position of governor of great Britain,
and he was also the general of the Roman army in the year 60 king PRUs.
He died and queen Boudicca became the new leader of the Isai tribe. Of course,
that Romans did not see Boudicca as a legitimate leader because she was a woman.
As we mentioned earlier,
there were certain contracts in place before king Prague's.
I should have guaranteed his people's safety, but general polls.
He decided to ignore all of this and take the is, and eye by force.
He used the loan as an excuse,
and he demanded that he wanted all 40 million SES to be paid back in full plus
interest. And he needed it all back immediately.
The Romans went into every single high,
taking anything of value that they could find. They captured men as slaves,
and they raped the young women, not even the young princesses were spared.
But's daughters were sexually assaulted by Roman soldiers.
When she tried to rescue her daughters, the soldiers grabbed the queen,
ripped her clothes off and beat her bloody in front of our people.
Since king PRUs truly did leave that plan to the Romans.
The CALS could only stand and watch as their beloved queen was brutalized in
front of them. Boudicca had been beaten,
but she was not broken instead of Withing and self-pity this attack.
It only sparked her need for a revenge.
Boudicca called with the leaders of the local tribes and learns that they had
all been treated in the same way.
Everyone was furious at what the Romans had done.
The leaders of several Celtic tribes.
They all agreed to put aside their differences and follow her as their new
queen. It was clear that if the cults wanted their freedom,
they were going to have to fight for it.
Boudicca had witnessed her husband's defeat against the Romans years earlier.
And yes, she was not afraid to fight them. Once again, for her people's freedom,
armed with a sword and her horse drawn chert Boudicca stood in front of her
Celtic warriors, just like her men, her face would've been a dawned in paint.
Women were fighting alongside men and each and every one of them had the fire of
vengeance in their hearts.
The kelps began the rebellion by targeting the Roman city of Camelo Duna,
which is modern day Colchester.
She waited until general POIs was out of town and he took his troops with him.
He was on a campaign to capture NGSE, which is an island in Wales.
Since he took all of his sold just with him, he left Camelo Duna,
virtually unfunded. Once he was gone Boudicca and a man,
they entered the city and they slaughtered all of the Roman men that they could
find when Roman leadership got word that they needed help defending the city
from a tribal queen who was leading rebellion.
They grossly underestimated her since she was a woman.
They sent a measly 200 unarmed slaves do take care of the issue.
Obviously, this handful of men were nothing compared to a massive army of
120,000 people.
And additional 2,500 Roman soldiers were sent to help defend the city.
For several days,
the soldiers tried to keep civilians alive by hoarding themselves in the temple
of courts.
The kelps grew tired of waiting and they set far to the temple were which
trapped and killed everyone inside. When general POS returned to the city,
he found the temple crumbling in a pile of ashes. Well,
as the gruesome scene of beheaded men, dissected bodies and pools of blood,
he knew that a small Legion of 5,000 men would be no match for Boudicca.
So he had no choice, but to ride ahead to each major,
Roman stronghold and try to evacuate civilian refugees before it was too late,
historian,
Cassius di wrote all this ruin was brought upon the Romans by a woman, a fact,
which in itself caused them the greatest shame. Next,
the kelps moved onto London, which is, as you would imagine, modern day London,
they burned the entire city to the ground. While in London,
tribal men who had been enslaved by the Romans,
they were set free and they began to follow Boudicca.
Her army temporarily grew to over 230,000 troops. They sang the city of Verium,
which is modern dals.
It is estimated that Boudicca's army killed and tortured between 70
thousands to 80,000 Roman people in the Roman history books.
They described the Celtic slaughter as being truly Bob Barrack. Some modern,
a historians believed that this imagery was exaggerated in order to demonize the
Celtic culture, just like every other colonizing nation.
The Romans believed that they were the more civilized ones,
even though they started the fight by attacking, robbing,
and raping the Celtic people beforehand Boudicca and the rest of the Celts were
steadily making progress to regain the Britain's independence from the Roman
empire. At this point,
Emper Niro was seriously considering pulling his Roman troops outta great
Britain. If Boudicca kept up killing his people at such a rapid rage,
she could topple the entire empire. And if she had succeeded at that,
she would on down in history as the queen who United the Celtic tribes under a
common cause and regains their independence.
But unfortunately for her general polls was confident that he could win.
He convinced emperor narrow to stay because he was ready with a strategy that
was going to take down the resistance once. And for all.
The final confrontation was known as the battle of Watling street.
As the name suggests the two armies met as a Roman road called Watling street,
while there is a map of this road,
most historians disagree over the exact location because there is only a brief
description of the location given by the historian TAUs general P chose this
location, because it was ideal for his defensive strategy.
The forest protected the back of the Roman soldiers.
So they could not be attacked from behind further.
There was an open field in front of the forest,
which forced Bo's army to charge straight towards them. As I mentioned earlier,
general POS only had 5,000 soldiers in his army.
He had to send a letter to all of the veterans living in great and who were much
older and enjoying their retirements.
Luckily for him and additional 5,000 men were still loyal to the empire and he
was able to assemble a total of 10,000 troops. Even after calling for backup.
He was outnumbered by boas army, according to Remini historian,
Cassius Dio queen Boca spent time before the battle giving a long and riveting
speech about fighting for freedom.
That rather sounds like it's straight out of a Hollywood movie.
It reads if you weigh well, the strengths of our armies,
you will see that in this battle, we must conquer or die.
This is a woman's resolve as for the men. They may live or be slaves.
I am not fighting for my kingdom and wealth.
Now I am fighting as an ordinary person for my lost freedom,
bruised body and my outrage daughters. However,
Cass D wasn't even there to listen. And in fact,
there were very few witnesses who actually survived. Therefore,
we can't be sure if the speech was actually like this at all.
This is especially the case where we consider that she spends a lot of time
trying to convince her troops that even though she's just a woman,
they should still trust her.
Anyway, if you really think about a hundred thousand kelps,
wouldn't really be there. If they didn't trust her in the first place,
further archeological evidence suggests that kelps had given women positions of
power in the military for hundreds of years before this.
But we'll get to that later. The kelps, they had plenty of weapons,
plenty of supplies that they had scavenged from the various Roman cities that
they had defeated. However,
they were still not as well equipped as the Roman army Roman soldiers,
they wore full suits of armor,
helmets and sandals with nails at the bottom to help them from slipping in the
grass. They also had swords and large shields, their Spears.
They could be thrown long distances, which helped them to avoid hand,
hand combat. Despite these setbacks,
the Celtic people were so confident that they would win the battle that they
even brought a wagon train with their wives and children.
The wagons formed a semicircular around the back of the Celtic army ceiling off
the exit. According to records,
general POIs could see the fear in his men's eyes as they stand at this army,
that was 10 times larger than their own,
but he used to snap the fear out of his men.
He tried to boost their morale by mocking the enemy.
He said that the kelps were savages and pointed to the female warriors as
evidence that they were weaker than the Romans, just like he did with Modica,
the historian Cassio invented yet another long. And Grandi speech for general.
Poist to say to his troops while we might not know exactly what words were
exchanged, do know what the General's battle strategy was.
He knew that even though his army had fewer men,
that they had a great advantage with their technology,
the Roman soldiers stood side to side and crouched together behind their
shields. During the first rounds of battle,
the counts charged towards the Romans who threw their Spears into the air
without having metal armor to protect them.
The Spears went through the chain mail and the bare chests of the Celtic
warriors, who to get told the men to fall back before pressing on once more,
when the kelps pushed up against this wall of Roman shields,
the Romans would draw their swords and stab the men in the chests.
Every few minutes, the Roman soldiers would rotate.
And the man who was just fighting was moved to the back of the line this way,
each man was fresh and ready for battle.
And he gave every everyone a chance to rest.
After the K council had exhausted thousands of their soldiers,
general pollers gave the order for his men to push themselves together into a
triangular formation. They then charged towards the Celtic army.
This was a very powerful maneuver that pushed against the men.
And it forced the Celtic people to retreat Cass S D wrote the remainder,
took to flight.
Although escape was difficult as the quarter of wagons that blocks the outlets.
The troops gave no quarter, even to the women,
the baggage animals themselves had been sped and added to the pile of bodies.
According to Roman records, 80,000 Celtic men,
women and children were killed during the battle of Watling street.
And just 400 Roman soldiers died at the hands of Boudicca army.
After losing the battle records say that Boudicca managed to run while we do not
know what happened next,
Taita speculated that she would've poisoned herself because it would've been the
honorable thing to do at the time. Her,
the Cassius Dio wrote that she had later died of an illness.
Ultimately we do not know when or how Boudicca died for years. Her story,
it was a bit forgotten.
This was an embarrassing stain in the Roman Empire's history.
So it only made sense that it was buried for quite some time,
but during the Renaissance, the story of the Keta Queen's bravery,
it began to emerge. Once again,
she was remembered and she was painted by artists. And during the Victorian era,
statues were created in AADA.
It didn't take long before she became a British icon.
Despite the detailed Roman records,
some people began to wonder if she even existed at all and considered the
possibility that this warrior queen may have actually just been a legend.
In fact, even the name Boudicca comes from the Celtic word, meaning victorious.
At the very least,
there is a chance that Boudicca may not have been her real name means it was
just a placeholder put in place of a true identity.
It was in the Victorian era that Boudicca's fame.
It finally took on legendary proportions.
As queen Victoria came to be seen as Boudicca's namesake their names being
identical in meaning Victoria's poet.
Alfred Lord Tannon wrote a poem Burea and several ships were named after her.
In 2001,
archeologists uncovered a burial side of a Celtic female warrior who was laid to
rest with a huge amount of respect at her feat with small treasures,
including a mirror broach and blue glass beads, a chariot,
it was decorated with red coral gathered from the sea.
Two other soldiers were buried next to this and, and are chariot.
These are known as the wet Wang graves and all of the artifacts from the
archeological sites. They're now kept at the British museum,
according to Tony Spence,
who works at the department of prehistory in Europe for the British museum.
They believe that this woman was a queen because of the special care and respect
that was given to her remains her chariots and the other objects surrounding her
were also expensive. Only royalty could afford such an extravagant burial.
She would've been in her late thirties to early forties, and she was very tall.
They were also able to use her skulls,
do a facial reconstruction of what she would've looked like her face was
disfigured. So it's easy to see how she could be described as frightening,
just like how Cassius di described Boca,
despite the fact that nearly every detail seems to line up with the story of
Boca, carbon dating done by Oxford university in 2017,
placed these artifacts anywhere between the years of 145 to 200 BC,
which would've been about two to 300 years before Boudicca's battle took place.
The scientists are now saying that carbon dating has the potential to be wrong.
In 2018 Cornell university did an experiment which showed proof of carbon dating
that was offset by several hundred years.
This means that many of the historical timelines we've been taught about ancient
civilizations could actually be rather wrong without a written record,
or until we invent a time machine.
We may never know the full story behind the true identities of these people in
those graves.
And indeed it will probably remain an unsold mystery forever,
but whether the wet Wang grave belongs to Bodah or not,
it still proves undoubtedly that the cults included warrior women in battle.
And if they were really 200 years before Bah's time,
it only goes to show that in ancient Britain,
women were respected enough to lead armies for several generations.
The remains of this warrior queen may sit in plastic bags and hardboard boxes in
a museum.
But the spirit of these leaders are still very much alive in the hearts of
everyone who stands up against their repressors.
Even if she was on the losing side of the war, Bodah truly was a hero.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting and inspiring. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below, and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several days a week.
If you hit that bell button as well,
you'll find out about when we put these videos out. So why not do that?
Give it a, like all of that good stuff. And as always, I'll see you next time.
I.